>>> BREAKING NEWS.
U.S. SECRET SERVICE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR TONY ORNOTO HAS LEFT
THE AGENCY.
THIS COMES TO US ACCORDING TO
TWO SOURCES.
IT COMES TWO MONTHS AFTER THE
EXPLOSIVE TESTIMONY BY FORMER
WHITE HOUSE AIDE CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON.
YOU'LL REMEMBER SHE DETAILED
WHAT SHE WAS TOLD WAS A HEATED
EXCHANGE THAT TRUMP HAD WITH A
SECRET SERVICE AGENT AFTER HIS
SPEECH ON JANUARY 6th.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID SOMETHING
TO THE EFFECT OF, I'M THE F'ing
PRESIDENT, TAKE ME UP TO THE
CAPITOL NOW.
TO WHICH BOBBY RESPONDED, SIR,
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO THE WEST
WING.
THE PRESIDENT REACHED UP TOWARDS
THE FRONT OF THE VEHICLE TO GRAB
AT THE STEERING WHEEL.
MR. ENGLE GRABBED HIS ARM, SAID
SIR, YOU NEED TO TAKE YOUR HAND
OFF THE STEERING WHEEL.
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE WEST
WING.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE CAPITOL.
MR. TRUMP THEN USED HIS FREE
HAND TO LUNGE TOWARDS BOBBY
ENGLE AND WHEN MR. ORNOTO HAD
RECOUNTED THE STORY TO ME, HE
MOTIONED TOWARDS HIS CLAVICLES.
>> LET'S GO TO WHITNEY WILD OUR
COLLEAGUE "OUTFRONT" IN
WASHINGTON.
THIS IS FIRST ON CNN REPORTING.
CASSIDY SAID UNDER OATH IT WAS
TONY ORNOTO WHO RECOUNTED THAT
EPISODE BETWEEN THE SECRET
SERVICE AGENT AND THE THEN
PRESIDENT.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT WHY
HE'S LEAVING?
>> THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF HIS
DEPARTURE ARE NOT CLEAR, BUT
WHAT SOURCES HAVE TOLD US IS
THIS HAD BEEN IN THE WORKS FOR A
LONG TIME.
HE HAD BEEN TALKING ABOUT
LEAVING THE AGENCY.
HE WAS ELIGIBLE TO RETIRE IN
JULY.
SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING, ALTHOUGH
THE TIMING IS OBVIOUSLY
CONSPICUOUS.
SO MANY MORE QUESTIONS TO BE
ANSWERED ABOUT WHY TODAY, WHY A
MONDAY IN AUGUST THAT HE LEFT.
BUT POPPY, I THINK WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER HERE IS
THAT THIS IS COMING AT A TIME
WHEN THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
HAS MADE VERY CLEAR THEY THINK
HE IS A VERY CRUCIAL WITNESS TO
WHAT HAPPENED LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6th AS WELL AS TRUMP'S
MINDSET.
REMEMBER, THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING
FOR THE MINDSET OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ON JANUARY 6th.
THEY VERY CLEARLY THINK THAT HE
WAS CRUCIAL TO THAT.
ALTHOUGH TONY ORNOTO, ACCORDING
TO CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TESTIMONY, WAS NOT IN THE LIMO
AT THE TIME, HE BECAME IRATE
WHEN HE LEARNED HE WOULD NOT BE
TAKEN TO THE CAPITOL BY HIS
DETAIL, HE'S STILL A CRUCIAL
FIGURE, AND REMEMBER, POPPY, HIS
GENERAL REASON FOR BEING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GAINING GREATER
SCRUTINY BECAUSE HE WAS IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED ROLE.
HE WAS STILL IN SOME WAYS
TECHNICALLY AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
SECRET SERVICE, BUT HE WAS ON
WHAT WAS BASICALLY A DETAIL TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AS THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF STAFF, IT WAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED MOVE TO TAKE A
POLITICAL ROLE WITHIN THE WHITE
HOUSE WHILE STILL IN SOME WAYS
AGAIN BEING WITH THE SECRET
SERVICE.
HE EVENTUALLY LEFT AND BECAME
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR.
NOW HE'S LEAVING, POPPY, BUT
CERTAINLY A MOMENTOUS SHAKEUP
OVER THERE.
>> FOR SURE.
WE'LL REMEMBER THERE WAS QUITE
THE BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
SECRET SERVICE, YOU KNOW, AND
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S TESTIMONY
AFTER.
AFTERWARD.
WHITNEY WILD, THANKS VERY MUCH.
"OUTFRONT" NOW, STEPHANIE
GRISHAM, FORMER PRESS SECRETARY
FOR FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND
OLIVIA TROYE, WHO WAS A
COUNTERTERRORISM ADVISER TO THEN
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, ALSO A
LIFELONG REPUBLICAN.
THANK YOU BOTH.
IF WE COULD START WITH THIS
BREAKING NEWS JUST IN TO CNN.
HOW SIGNIFICANT DO YOU THINK IT
IS TONY ORNOTO IS LEAVING THE
SECRET SERVICE AT THIS MOMENT
WHEN THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
CLEARLY WANTS MORE TESTIMONY
FROM HIM, LIKELY PUBLIC?
>> YEAH, I THINK THE TIMING IS
SUSPECT AND INTERESTING.
I WONDER WHAT THIS MEANS, HE'LL
BE A PRIVATE CITIZEN, WHAT DOES
THIS MEAN GOING FORWARD AS THE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS START UP
AGAIN.
I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S PROBABLY
BEST FOR THE SECRET SERVICE THAT
TONY ORNOTO IS LEAVING.
HE CERTAINLY BROUGHT A LOT OF
DISGRACE AND SHAME TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK THERE.
WHO ARE GREAT PEOPLE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT I HAVE GOTTEN
TO KNOW.
I THINK IT WILL BE INTERESTING
TO SEE HOW THESE PLAYS OUT AND
I'M ALSO VERY CURIOUS TO SEE
WHERE HIS FUTURE EMPLOYMENT WILL
BE.
>> STEPHANIE, ONE THING OUR
VIEWERS SHOULD KNOW IS ORNOTO
ACTUALLY MET WITH THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
THIS WAS, ALBEIT BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, AND THE COMMITTEE HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR, THEY BELIEVE THAT
HE IS A KEY FIGURE IN ALL THIS
WHO COULD, AS WHITNEY JUST
REPORTED, REALLY SHED LIGHT ON
THE PRESIDENT'S MINDSET ON THE
DAY OF THE INSURRECTION AND HIS
DESIRE TO BE TAKEN TO THE
CAPITOL AFTER THAT SPEECH.
HOW CRITICAL DO YOU THINK IT IS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HEAR FROM
HIM?
>> OH, I THINK IT'S VITAL THAT
THE COMMITTEE HEARS FROM HIM.
I THINK IT WOULD BE VITAL THAT
THE PUBLIC COULD HEAR FROM HIM,
ALTHOUGH I THINK THAT WON'T
HAPPEN.
CERTAINLY NOW THAT HE'S LEAVING
THE SECRET SERVICE, IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THEY WERE GOING TO
COOPERATE, ALBEIT THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED YET.
WHEN I SPOKE TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, I SAID OVER AND OVER
THAT TONY ORNOTO IS A KEY PERSON
TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS GO ON,
AS DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
OPERATIONS, YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON LOGISTICALLY,
BEHIND THE SCENES, AND
POLITICALLY.
YOU KIND OF HAVE T